in this video we'll talk about liver
function test
please use a headphone for better audio
quality
so what is liver function test
liver function test is a blood test
that determines what is the
functionality of the liver whether the
liver is damaged due to a disease or an
injury
how does liver function test works
liver function test actually determines
level of certain enzymes and protein in
our blood
many of these proteins and enzymes are
not supposed to be in elevated level in
our blood but if their levels are
elevated that would be indicative of any
kind of liver injury
now let's talk about how liver
functioning test is performed so it's
just a blood test here a medical
technician draws some amount of blood
from you and from the blood several
tests are performed and these tests can
be used to screen for liver infections
such as hepatitis
it can be used to monitor the
progression of a disease such as viral
or alcoholic hepatitis
it can measure the severity of a disease
particularly in case of fatty liver
disease or cirrhosis
it can also monitor the possible side
effects of a given medication
let's see how liver functioning test
really works
so liver functioning test determines
bunch of enzymes from our blood
now it would tell us how well the liver
is performing in its and
how its normal function is affected due
to some injury
for example liver generally clears out
bilirubin this particular test would
tell us how well it can do so
now there are certain enzymes and
proteins and elements which are tested
in this particular blood test
these are alanine transaminase alg
these are aspartate transaminase ast
alkaline phosphatase alp albumin
gamma-glutamyl transferase or ggt
l-lactate dehydrogenase ld prothrombin
time and bilirubin all of these array of
tests are performed to understand the
overall health and whether there is an
injury in the liver or not
now the first and the foremost
important thing is the alt and ast
levels
alt and asd are important for amino acid
metabolism
ald converts alanine into pyruvate ast
converts aspartate into oxaloacetate
and thereby they are really important
for amino acid metabolism
their normal level
is given here
if their level
is increased than the normal blood
levels that would be indicative of liver
injury generally
and asd is very low in blood but they
are highly enriched in the liver when
there is an injury in the liver they
leak out into the blood and that's why
we can find them more often in the blood
next alkaline phosphatase is really
important factor that is determined in
the liver functioning test
normal level is 40 to 120 units per
liter
alkaline phosphatase is an enzyme that
is produced by the liver also found in
bone and other extra hepatic tissues
and it helps in breaking down proteins
higher than normal level of alkaline
phosphatase is an indicative of liver
damage such as shirosis hepatitis a
blockage in the bile duct or many other
things such as swelling of the liver
now prothomine time is another parameter
to understand
or it's an important parameter to assess
the liver functioning
normal protonment time is 10.9 seconds
to 12.5 seconds
this is the time that is required for a
blood to coagulate
so liver produces prothomine and many
other coagulation factor all of these
factors are important for clotting
now if there is
less production of these factors
that means liver function is compromised
and that is why the prothombrian time is
now increased so any increase in
protamine
time would increase the time for blood
clot and that would be an indicative of
liver damage
now proton in time can be elevated due
to other reasons as well and it is not
exclusive to liver damage for example if
you have a vitamin k deficiency or you
might be suffering from a
clotting disorder
it's also possible that you are taking
some kind of drug that is a blood
thinning agent such as warfarin
now next thing is bilirubin
bilirubin tells us a lot about liver's
function bilirubin is generated by rbc
destruction hemp protein catabolism and
sometimes due to bone marrow
erythropoiesis
bilirubin gets into the liver gets
conjugated in a conjugated bilirubin
form then ultimately in the large
intestine it forms the fecal
starcobilion chain and that's how it is
excreted and that's how liver
efficiently
excretes and metabolize bilirubin
now if there is too much of bilirubin
then there is a problem
and it is in case of liver injury such
as let's say jaundice it has been seen
the bilirubin level is elevated
alternatively in diseases like hemolytic
anemia the level of bilirubin can be
increased because rbc destruction
ultimately give rise to bilirubin
so it's also an important indicative of
liver's function 1.2 milligrams per
deciliter is the normal level of
bilirubin in adults
next we should talk about gamma
glutamine transferase or gdt this is an
important enzyme
and this is also
present in liver and it is only present
in the blood
when there is a liver damage in that
time it leaks into the bloodstream
higher than normal levels would indicate
there is a obstructive bile duct damage
or a liver damage
now we understood this kind of basic
biology and how these enzymes are really
important in context of
liver
now let's try to understand how to
interpret the
liver functioning test result
so these are some sample reports
here you can see all the parameters and
all these parameters are now familiar
with you guys such as alkaline
phosphatase altast
then serum globulin then bilirubin all
of these things are kind of like very
familiar right now right so in the right
hand side you can see the normal range
is provided and you have to understand
the values fall within the normal range
or outside the normal range then it has
to be correlated from a clinical
perspective to understand or interpret
the disease
in the sample report 2 you can see there
is an elevation of alt and asd that
indicate there is something wrong
but in order to understand what has gone
wrong other histories has to be taken
and thorough analysis has to be done
let me tell you why it is really
important none of these factors
individually are important but a
combination of factor can tell us much
about the disease
for example alt is much more specific in
context of a liver disease than ast if
we put it in a clinical perspective
in case of let's say alcoholic hepatitis
alt doesn't go over 300
but there is an increased asd alt ratio
in case of
let's say non-alcoholic steatohepatitis
there is often a low ast alt ratio
now marked elevation in alt asd levels
are seen in many cases such as liver
injury viral hepatitis ischemically
liver injury all of these cases
not only alt but asd but there are other
enzymes which can tell us many things
about liver injury such as alkaline
phosphatase
such as ggt levels let's say you have a
very high alkaline phosphatis level but
a normal ggt level that could indicate
there is extra hepatic injury if there
are elevation of both alp and ggt there
could there could be a
injury in the bile duct so all of these
parameters would tell us about how our
liver is functioning
in in a particular clinical perspective
so i hope this was useful
you can get a lot of notes and flash
cards in my facebook page and instagram
page my facebook and instagram handle
are same and this is given here
also the link is provided in the
description you can support me via
patreon or beam upi app if you're an
indian viewer alternatively you can
support my channel by clicking on the
super like option you can connect to me
via various social media all the links
are provided in the description don't
forget to like share and subscribe let
me know in the comment whether these
things are useful and if you have